celebrate
and thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh good you are here i presume this is
my new recruit
i was getting quite impatient
you have your credentials on you
well this all looks very promising
yes good oh
you worked for darwin rangan hope he
went there on the day of his tragic
death
okay soul looks very good come on
let's walk i need to tell you a bit
about what i expect from you
i expect you to be by my side 24 7
and as i say otherwise bathroom breaks
are of course permitted but only when i
say so
they have a very important delicate
meeting today
in which i expect you to keep your ears
closed but your eyes
wide open understood your papers were
indeed
impressive but i need to see what you
can do with my own eyes
my father used to take me hunting i was
an avid hunter
i personally hated it but always admired
his skill with a knife
and grew to appreciate what it takes to
gut an animal
have you ever tried to cut an animal yes
good
then you know it's not so easy as it
looks
like trying to stab a rubber ball bounce
his back if you don't
stab it correctly you're almost here you
have to understand
i didn't get where i am by blind thing
okay we are almost there you see the
shooting targets
any fool can shoot a target with a knife
that's where the talent lies my father
always used to say
if you are good with a knife or even
better with a gun
i want to see your skills i don't know
why but i've always
trusted a man who could throw a knife
i'm sure psychiatrist would have a field
day with that statement
if you see a man with a bodyguard it
draws attention understood
yeah of course you do come on follow me
you got him 47. marcus stuyvesant won't
be a problem anymore
let's move on to carl ingram we're not
done
yet no one is supposed to know that i'm
here
however there's a journalist down at the
inauguration
and he's asking rather intrusive
questions about who's staying up here
and that is a very dangerous problem for
me
now i want you to silence this little
pain
you think you can do that it's what i do
best i like your bluntness
this is his file hands looked
bullets are winning freelance journalist
he's good
and
give up until he gets the answers he
needs and that
can't happen consider it done good man
and remember i want a picture i want
proof so i can sleep tonight
of course once this little assignment is
completed come back and talk to miss toe
then we can discuss the real cancer that
needs to be removed
i'm sure you can see yourself out
that's karl ingram providence partner
and brass balls billionaire
a legendary political fixer ingram is
old money and as rotten as they come
you know what's happening upstairs i
know more than you could imagine
but we can't talk here follow me great
lead the way yes hello sir
oh no so what happened here
that uh that looks a bit gold mister
i hope you have had time to see the art
exhibition
his royal highness has a keen eye for
the arts
if you haven't yet i highly recommend it
[Music]
so good to see you you have the picture
yes your problem is
fixed no more said you were good
let's get down to the important business
at hand
okay people clear the room i need to
discuss some delicate business with mr
cuisine
perfect we have ingram right where we
want him excuse me for a second 47
you know what to do
all right where were we not yet
my man here will stay for the meeting i
assume that will not be a problem
either way you have no choice in the
matter
i think i'll join you anyway i was
saying
it's interesting we haven't come across
each other
we've gotten soon there will be no more
providence
you need to find an exit our business is
done here but it's far from over
[Music]
[Music]
you